[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> 13 years ago,
it was my freshman year of college, 2006.
And I was attending my first meeting of
the Association of Black Harvard women.
I was so excited to meet fellow black
women classmates for the first time.
We went around in a circle
introducing ourselves.
The first woman to go happened
to have a Nigerian name.
She said, hi, my name's Adora Escunananay,
it mean's a child who is
one of the community.
Who is given to all and
whom all must look after.
Then, the second girl went.
She said hi, my name is Suran Al Alazah,
it means a sacred flower,
one found in the Bible
that is especially sacred.
Then it was my turn, I said,
hi, my name is Mercedes Bent.
It means, well,
it's kind of just like the car.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That moment seeded a curiosity in
me about African names.
I was so
interested in the beauty of the names.
12 years later, I would find
myself leading a trip to Ghana and
Nigeria with Stanford and
Harvard classmates where we were going
to explore our heritage and our roots.
I had started calling
the trip my black birthright.
When I think back on what
inspired me to plan such a trip,
I think back to that day my freshman
year of college and to two other times.
The second time was also in
college when I first learned about
the Jewish birthright or
[FOREIGN] birthright Israel trip.
My friends in college told me about this
all expenses paid trip where they got to
go visit Israel, learn about their
heritage, connect to their people and
get really indoctrinated in
what it meant to be Jewish.
I was like, that's so
cool why don't we have that?
The third incident that inspired the trip
was a few years later when I was in
the working world.
It was 2016 and I was sitting at
my desk one day, when my phone and
computer started blowing
up with notifications.
I clicked on a link.
And what I saw next horrified me.
There was a video streaming on Facebook
Live of a man who had just been shot.
His fiance or
a girlfriend was sitting next to him in
the side seat was filming the aftermath.
Her four year old daughter
was in the backseat.
They had just he had just been shot
after being pulled over by the police
on a routine traffic stop and had been
shot about seven times in 40 seconds.
My mind started raising.
I started thinking,
why did someone shoot into the car so
quickly right after
a routine traffic stop?
Why would someone shoot into the car?
There was a little girl in the back seat.
What if it had been my dad or
brother in the front seat?
What if I had been
the little girl in the back?
His name was Philando Castile.
That was the incident that
jolted me very deeply.
The rest of the day at work, I tried
to focus on getting things done and
being a productive member of the team.
But unfortunately, my teammates didn't
get anything from me the rest of the day.
I couldn't focus.
Later that week, I called my friend and
I said we've gotta do something.
We've gotta help black people.
We looked into how we could support
economic empowerment initiatives or
how we could support Black Lives Matter.
We donated and rallied,
but nothing quite stuck.
We were still yearning to do more.
It would take another two years before
I found a solution that did stick.
And it ended up being my trip to Ghana and
Nigeria.
I didn't realize it at the time
that it would become a solution.
But it did end up being one, in a way.
The trip itself was full of new and
exciting adventures.
We went to concerts where we
danced all night to Afro beats.
I learned how to cook jollof rice,
a dish that is a staple of African
diets and has inspired intense rivalry.
I got my hair braided, we discussed
Nigerian politics and history.
And I even got a new name.
So I participated in
a traditional Nigerian naming
ceremony where they gave me a name.
Assosa Adowa Olakay,
Assosa means God's gift.
Adowa means born on a Monday.
And Olakay is the family name.
They said to me, you will always
have a family here in Nigeria.
Welcome to the family.
For the first time in my life, I felt
a surge of gratitude and appreciation as I
realized I finally felt connected to
the people of the African continent,
to my people.
Over the course of the trip, I realized
that my mind was really being put at ease.
That the recurring racial soundtrack
caused by microaggressions
in the United States
was starting to lessen.
That I was healing mentally,
that I was healing through heritage.
Over the course of that trip
I also thought about well,
what if I lived here in Ghana or Nigeria?
I wouldn't be subjected to as many
racially charged microaggressions and
I wouldn't have to wonder if I was hired
for my token, or for my potential.
Research shows that the development of
ethnic and racial identity can have really
positive benefits for
a minoritized youth and young adults.
These positive benefits can
include higher self-esteem,
greater confidence and even higher
academic achievement in school.
Research has also shown that
in interventions rooted
in indigenous traditions,
have had the effect of
decreasing substance abuse and
attempts at suicide.
So what I'm talking about here,
the developing an ethnic and
racial identity and
connecting to your heritage,
is not just a matter of having higher
self-esteem or having greater confidence.
Although those could be great benefits,
it can be a matter of life or death.
I strongly believe that anybody,
any displaced person who has been
displaced whether due to freeing for
a new country or simply immigrating for
a better life, can benefit from
planning their own birthright trip and
finding some of the healing that I did.
So where do I go from here?
As I said, thought about,
if I lived in the Ghana or Nigeria,
some of the healing benefits I would get,
but if I lived there,
I wouldn't get to live
here in the United States.
Where we have the greatest melting
pot experiment going on that
the world's ever seen.
Call me an optimist, but
I still share Martin Luther King's
dream that one day, we won't be
judged by the color of our skin.
I'm committed to helping
more young adults,
more youth of minoritized backgrounds,
go on trips, such as the one is I did.
I've gotten involved with an organization
called Birthright AFRICA.
And I'm hoping that together we
can help them raise money to send
more people on these trips.
I hope that in sharing my
story today with you guys,
a short story of the healing
that I went through,
that you're either inspired to
go find your own birthright or
support those of us on this journey.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]